Android Wear devices operate in two
main modes, interactive, and ambient.
Your watch face design should
take these modes in account.
When the user moves their wrist
to glance at their watch, or
if the user touches it,
the screen goes into interactive mode.
Your design can use full color,
with fluid animation,
along with a background image or
gradient in this mode.
And you can press the side button
to go back into ambient mode, or
it will time out by itself.
Ambient mode helps
the device conserve power.
Your watch face design needs to include
a separate design for ambient mode.
How similar or
different it is, is up to you.
Your watch face can use some color,
such as that red there,
on screens that support it.
As long as it's still obvious that
the device is in ambient mode.
In this mode, the screen is
only updated once every minute.
So you should not show the second hands
that we saw moving around earlier.
Your watch face will spend most
of its time in ambient mode, so
you should thoughtfully design for it.